hey everyone it's Sarah threads earners
are en comm and in this video I'm going
to be doing an ink Lex practice question
specifically over calcitonin which is
used to treat osteoporosis so let's take
a look at our ink Lex practice question
your patient who has osteoporosis is
prescribed to take calcitonin which
assessment finding below is a possible
adverse reaction of this medication and
requires you to notify the physician
immediately a constipation B abdominal
pain that is found at one-third distance
between the bellybutton and anterior
superior iliac spine C carpeau pedal
spasm while assessing the patient's
blood pressure or D absent reflexes okay
so we learn from our scenario that this
patient has osteoporosis and that
they're prescribed calcitonin so we
really need to know what osteoporosis is
and what calcitonin is doing because if
we can understand those two processes we
can know hey what should we be looking
for as the nurse okay so let's do recap
about osteoporosis well we learned in
our latest in CLECs review that Osseo
process is thinning of those bones
specifically that spongy bone that's in
the bones it's already naturally porous
but what happens is it becomes
increasingly porous which lowers our
bone density so they're at risk from
fractures real easy fractures so inside
that spongy bone we talked about
osteoclasts and osteoblasts and
osteoclasts consume the material nut
matrix specifically calcium and puts it
back into our blood system and the
osteoblasts will take the calcium from
our blood system and build up that bone
matrix and keep it nice and strong
however with osteoporosis like the
patient was postmenopausal they have low
estrogen levels that can lead to
osteoporosis and things like that this
patient has been prescribed calcitonin
now calcitonin is naturally produced by
our thyroid gland and it helps maintain
our calcium levels in a sense it's one
of those hormones that play a role in
bone health so whatever our calcium
levels are high
our thyroid gland secretes calcitonin
sowhat's calcitonin going to do well
calcitonin will decrease osteoclast
activity so it's going to decrease how
these cells are consuming bone because
remember those cells consume bones and
it releases the calcium into the blood
we're going to slow that down because we
don't want to be wasting any more of our
bone matrix we need it and this is going
to allow those osteoblasts in a sense to
outwork those osteo class because we're
going to be building up bone better than
we're actually breaking it down but this
is going to really mess with our calcium
levels because we're not going to have
those osteoclasts to go in there and
break that bone down to give us some
more calcium now also calcitonin messes
with how the kidneys excrete calcium
it's going to decrease it I mean it's
going to increase the secrete excretion
of calcium so you're going to be
releasing all this calcium into your
urine it's here me wasting it so blood
levels are going to draw up even more
and then your osteoclasts aren't going
to be as active and bringing down that
bone and getting that calcium from the
bones so what's going to happen to our
calcium levels possibly and we have to
monitor the patient for this we have to
monitor them for hypocalcemia so
whenever you were looking at your
options you need to be thinking about
that electrolyte imbalance so in order
to best answer this question we need to
know how calcitonin really worked and
one of its side effects if we have too
much going on in the system we can have
hypocalcemia so let's look at our
options and see which one goes along
with hypocalcemia okay
a constipation closer patient is
actually seen in hypercalcemia because
what happens is that it slows down that
GI tract that stool just sets in their
stool becomes hard it's hard to pass and
the patient becomes constipated so
that's other side so hyper calcium is
where you would see that okay be
abdominal pain one third isn't this
between the bellybutton and anterior
iliac spine well they like to throw
stuff out there a - like this because it
looks abnormal it's like man that's not
good by is it really going to be seen in
a condition of a patient taking
calcitonin no this is what's called
McBurney's point this area right here
and this is what is seen in appendicitis
we learned about that in our
appendicitis video so this was an
appendix question that would be a red
flag but not here okay see cargo pedo
spasms while assessing patient's blood
pressure hmm what is this this is true
so sign and remember when we learned
when we were talking about hypocalcemia
we talked about true so sign being
positive and what is this this is where
if you put some type of device like a
blood pressure cuff or maybe even a
tourniquet on that patient's upper arm
and it occludes the blood flow through
that brachial artery and the calcium
levels are low enough it will cause
these carpeau pedal spasms and what's
happened is that involuntarily that
wrist is gonna flex and the thumb is
going to abduct and the fingers aflame
these are going to like extend and
they're going to they may even complain
a tingling while this is happening in
pain and it's just gonna go up like that
while you're possibly taking the blood
pressure and that would be a huge red
flag you start them on calcitonin you're
taking their blood pressure all of a
sudden you see that happening so that is
true so sign also they may have a
positive chip at sixteen which is that
hyperexcitability of the muscular
neuromuscular system where you tap on
the Meseta muscle in the face and
they'll have twitching of the nose or
the lips on that same side their
reflexes are actually going to be hyper
active so looking at things like that so
that why it would rule out D so our
answer would be C okay so that wraps up
this NCLEX practice review
question and be sure to check out the
other NCLEX questions in this series
thank you so much for watching and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
more videos